rue du balat bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on a
entendu un garde des sceaux qui s'est
déplacé hier à marseille il a promis
plus de moyens humains pour le parquet
des procédures traitées plus vite pour
les mineurs est ce que c'est une bonne
décision selon vous
bien sûr c'est une bonne décision dans
la mesure où aujourd'hui c'est le garde
des sceaux lui même qui l'a dit il faut
entre 15 et 18 mois pour juger un mineur
imaginiez quand un mineur de 16 ans est
convoqué 15 à 18 mois après pour délit
qu'il a fait est qu'à la fin de cette
convocation il a en rappel à la loi le
sentiment d'impunité se développe c'est
une catastrophe pour les policiers qui
travaillent sur le terrain maintenant ce
qui m'inquiète un peu plus c'est le
reportage que vous avez fait et la prise
de parole du syndicat de la magistrature
qui explique que les ondes c'est
absolument impossible à ce qu'ils
arrivent à marseille au mois de
septembre ça c'est une inquiétude
supplémentaire j'espère que ça peut être
en effet d'annonce en tout cas ni de
l'intérieur annoncé sans effectif pour
le coup lui il les a mais j'espère que
eric dupond-moretti n'a pas annoncé 11
pour faire plaisir à la galerie et à la
finition il y en aura que deux bon
qu'est ce qui va dans ce sens à toute
façon c'était intéressant mais talent de
salé si vous voulez juger qu un jour
après que voir me mettais en rappel à la
loi c'est pareil si léger 18 mois après
donc aujourd'hui sont non seulement les
convoquer vie qu'ils comprennent ce que
si la justice mais il faut également les
condamner sévèrement parce que si vous
condamnez pas sévèrement des gamins fait
quel jeu particulièrement pas maintenant
présent non plus un mais simuler
comdamné pas avec une fermeté ces
gamins-là ne comprennent rien ils ne
comprennent pas malheureusement que la
dureté c'est ça le noeud du problème
pour vous c'est pas forcément le manque
d'effectif ce sont les peines qui ne
sont pas appliquées
complètement
aujourd'hui il ya deux ans j'ai pas tout
les pourcentages en tête mais vous savez
aussi bien que moi qui a une grosse
majorité des peines qui ne sont pas
effectués ce qui est absolument
hallucinant c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes condamné à un an et demi en
prison nous ne les fait pas vous ne les
faites pas parce que vous avez embrassé
électronique ça c'est encore une
invention extraordinaire l'est le
bracelet électronique les jeunes ils
sont dans la rue et pavane avec le
bracelet électronique pour faire voir
que où ils ont une peine de prison ferme
ont fait ça on en parlera sur une autre
notre une autre fois je mets haut
mais clairement mansat devient quasiment
trop fait pour eux donc aujourd'hui il
faut comprendre que c'est quand il ya un
délit relativement graves aux communes
il faut qu'il y ait une condamnation
pénale derrière cette condamnation
pénale même si ces six mois de prison
ferme et des il faut que les six mois
soit réellement effectuées de manière à
ce que des gamins de 15 16 17 ans
puissent comprendre ce que c'est la
prison alors il y en a qui disent qu'en
prison il ressort qu'ils sont encore
plus violent mais il y en a tiré au sort
de prison aussi en se disant j'ai
vraiment pas envie d'y retourner parce
que ces cas une sacrée merde la prison
et j'ai plus envie d'y retourner il ya
les deux cas de figure sont simplement
on parle juste des gens qui ressortent
qui sont encore plus violentes qu'avant
il ya aussi des cas où ça peut faire du
bien à certains jeunes pour ne pas y
retourner alors une venue du garde des
sceaux dans un contexte à marseille de
trafic de drogue de trafic d'armes est
ce que aujourd'hui si on s'en donne est
vraiment les moyens on peut démanteler
ces trafics ou alors l'ampleur est
devenue trop importante
très clairement je vais pas vous dire
qu'on peut arrêter le phénomène en trois
semaines non c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui
l'ampleur des trafics est tellement
immense sur marseille 156 points de
vente de stupéfiants chaque point
rapporte entre 30 et 60 mille euros par
jour ça fait vivre des milliers de
familles donc aujourd'hui même si on
s'attaque au problème tous ensemble
parce que ça fait plusieurs jours et
j'ai l'impression que je commence à être
un petit peu écoutés qu'ils sont
ensemble parce que la police tout seul
vous l'avez bien compris n'arrivera pas
à résoudre ce problème donc aujourd'hui
on a besoin de l'éducation nationale
parce qu'il y en a marre que des enfants
de 13 14 15 ans sont déscolarisés et que
l'éducation nationale ne réagissent pas
à ça les enfants de 13 14 15 ans doit
être à l'école de la république en
france il faut que les travailleurs
sociaux puissent réintégrer ces cités de
manière à pouvoir porter une parole qui
est souvent nommé hier que les
trafiquants dessus il faut que la police
continue à faire son boulot comme elle
le fait aujourd'hui malheureusement elle
le fait seule il faut aussi que la
justice puisse condamner fermement ces
individus lorsqu'on les interpelle parce
que croyez bien sûr marseille on
interpelle énormément énormément j'ai et
je pèse mes mots d'individus pour des
trafics de stupéfiants et nous les
présentons très régulièrement la justice
gérald darmanin lui prend pose plus de
caméras de surveillance à marseille
qu'est ce que vous en dites
je trouve que l'idée est excellente
alors sa vie il ya eu sous l'ère gaudin
les deux dernières mandatures
effectivement il a développé les caméras
de vidéosurveillance
et croyez bien que ça aide la police a
interpellé deux individus alors là on
est tombé sur une mairie america était
lui un homme qui a considéré que les
caméras de vidéosurveillance ce n'était
pas utile bon il de bon le problème ce
qu'ils comprennent rien à la sécurité il
faudrait qu'il se passe expliqué par les
professionnels ce que c'est la sécurité
en l'occurrence les policiers mais ils
ont refusé de nous recevoir donc
aujourd'hui moi je me mêle pas des
questions d'écologie comprends et je
comprends rien mais sur me demandant mon
avis sur les questions de sécurité
peut-être jours on peut apporter notre
pierre à l'édifice je vous le dise
clairement les caméras de
vidéoprotection sont sommes plus bien
sûr qu'elles ne permettent pas d'arrêter
physiquement un individu par contre
quand il ya un délit ou un crime qui se
commet on peut faire en recoupements
mais les caméras de vidéosurveillance
qui nous permettent souvent de remonter
à l'individu qui a été auteur des faits
on a un exemple très précis très
marquant je sais pas si vous rappelez il
ya deux mois il ya une affaire qu'on
avait traité à orange mécanique à
marseille où un homme ou un monsieur
avait été marquée par quatre individus
nous avons remonté ces quatre individus
interpellés ces quatre individus grâce
aux caméras de vidéoprotection donc les
béni oui oui où tout le monde il est
beau tout le monde il est gentil décès
du politique qui pense comme ça qu'ils
pensent que les caméras de
vidéoprotection ne sont pas utiles à la
sécurité de ses concitoyens et des
concitoyens qui les ont élus à la mairie
ça veut dire qu'ils on a rien à faire de
la sécurité des marseillais il ya un
autre débat qui revient sur la table
c'est la question de la légalisation du
cannabis le maire-adjoint de marseille 1
notamment qui demande ça
en tant que policier comment est ce que
vous vous jugé cette proposition
pour nos policiers s'est totalement
inaudible déjà pris mon parce que ça
voudrait dire que déjà que c'est
compliqué pour nous déjà que l'autorité
de l'état n'existe pas trop ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on baisse complètement
notre culotte et on a perdu la guerre
sans amener ça c'est la première des
choses la deuxième des choses j'ai pas
envie d'avoir une société où mes enfants
puissent acheter de la résine de
cannabis
deux manières autorisés c'est pas
possible j'ai pas envie d'avoir des
enfants de 16 17 ans 18 ans qui fume des
stupéfiants sans qu'on puisse leur
reprocher de le faire on va faire que
des gens qui sont de lobotomiser non
maintenant on a conscience de la
difficulté qu entraîne le cannabis alors
il ya eu les études la turquie sont plus
ou moins plus ou moins sérieuses mais le
cannabis a un effet sur nos enfants donc
si on veut une société comme ça il faut
qu'on nous dise on veut une société
comme ça comme ça on aura des enfants
qui sont complètement anéanti par le
cannabis et puis derrière comme ça sera
pas suffisant mais passons la cocaïne et
comme derrière ça sera pas suffisant
parce qu'à l'origine on aurait une
société de drogués plus qu'un point à la
ligne alors on nous parle qu'il ya des
expériences dans d'autres pays qui
pourrait marcher il ya beaucoup
d'expérience qui n'ont pas marché où en
est revenue en arrière alors nous donne
l'exemple du canada nous sommes des
seuls en groupe ça commence à marcher
sauf que la société canadienne n'est pas
du tout la même que la société française
on arrive au terme de cette interview et
de cette matinale en tout cas merci à
vous d'avoir réagi ce matin sur rtl
frange le rappelle vous êtes secrétaire
départemental du syndicat de police
alliance dans les bouches du rhône